veamos cómo determinar el número de
señales esperadas en un espectro rml la
mejor manera de hacer esto es hacer
muchos modelos de práctica empezaremos
con metano y el metano tiene 4 protones
en el mismo ambiente debido a esto
decimos que esos 4 protones son
químicamente equivalentes y esperaríamos
ver solo una señal en el espectro de rm
n para el metano esperaríamos ver una
y al
porque todos los cuatro protones son
químicamente equivalentes si nos movemos
al propano este carbono de aquí tiene
dos protones
estos dos protones están en el mismo
ambiente por lo que son químicamente
equivalentes y esperaríamos ver sólo una
genial
para estos dos protones si vemos estos
protones de aquí déjame los incluyó en
el dibujo estos protones
estos protones del metilo están en su
propio ambiente aquí por lo que
esperaríamos una señal para estos
protones del metilo pero para una
molécula como esta tienes que pensar en
simetrías si dibuja una línea aquí es
fácil ver que estos tres protones están
en el mismo ambiente
realmente tenemos 6 protones en el mismo
ambiente estos 6 protones son
químicamente equivalentes y esperaríamos
ver una
real
para todos los seis así que para el
propano esperaríamos ver un total de dos
señales
continuamos con esta dibujemos nuestros
protones dibujemos los a todos primero
estoy dibujando todos los protones
tenemos estos protones de metilo aquí
y luego aquí tenemos un protón en este
carbono y luego tenemos todos estos
protones
hay muchos enfoquémonos en los protones
de metilo primero estos protones de
metilo aquí están en su propio ambiente
y ese ambiente es el mismo para todos
estos protones de metilo todos están en
el mismo ambiente todos al lado de un
carbono con un hidrógeno y entonces
esperaríamos ver solo una señal para
todos estos protones
una señal
una señal para los protones en magenta
nuevamente piensa en la simetría en la
simetría de esto y luego si veo este
protón de aquí este está en un ambiente
diferente a los protones magenta pero
está en el mismo ambiente que es
esperamos una señal para estos protones
señal para los protones en rojo un total
de un total de dos señales para la
molécula bien hagamos más ejemplos
continuamos con este ahora tenemos
aquí con dos protones en ella
y estos dos protones están en el mismo
ambiente son químicamente equivalentes
estos dos protones están junto a este
oxígeno de aquí sabemos que el oxígeno
es más electro negativo que el carbono
el oxígeno tomará algo de densidad
electrónica y entonces estos dos
protones están en un ambiente diferente
de estos dos protones estos dos protones
de aquí continuaré cambiando colores
estos protones en rojo están más lejos
del oxígeno están en un ambiente
diferente esperaríamos
la señal
de los protones en rojo y esperaríamos
una
y al de los protones en amarillo aún
tenemos nuestros protones de metilo
continuaré dibujando los tenemos
tres protones por aquí en este carbono
están bastante lejos del oxígeno están
en su propio ambiente son químicamente
equivalentes por lo que esperamos una
y al de estos protones finalmente no te
olvides del protón de aquí el protón del
oxígeno ese está en su propio ambiente
por lo que se espera una
genial
para este protón realmente un total si
las sumamos un total de cuatro señales
esperaríamos cuatro señales un total de
cuatro en este alcohol veamos este
alcohol de aquí abajo tenemos estos dos
protones
protones de aquí
y estos protones aquí
pensemos en eso la simetría ayuda en un
ejemplo como éste
estos dos protones están en el mismo
ambiente están entre 12 h 2 esperaríamos
una
ni al para estos protones son
químicamente equivalentes veamos
veamos estos protones estos de aquí
están junto a un ch 2 también al lado de
1 h es exactamente el mismo ambiente que
estos protones están junto a un ch 2 y
al lado de un h
así que si piensas en simetría aquí
esperaríamos solo una señal una c
y al
para estos cuatro protones y luego
finalmente aún tenemos tenemos el protón
en el oxígeno y luego nuevamente la
simetría nos ayuda a pensar en el hecho
de que este protón está en el mismo
ambiente que este protón esperaríamos
esperaríamos una
y al aire así que tenemos un total de
tres señales esperadas para esta
molécula continuamos con este compuesto
de aquí en la derecha puedes ver que hay
un centro quiral aquí en este carbono y
por ende debería de haber un hidrógeno
para este protón en ese carbono así que
continuemos y agreguemos todos los
protones
analicemos los aquí tenemos 3 protones
en este carbono en este carbono de aquí
tenemos dos protones y los estoy
dibujando con q naciones porque vamos a
tener que pensar en estos dos protones y
luego por aquí tenemos 3
de esta manera
bien pensemos en cuántas señales
diferentes tendremos en el pasado
déjame regresar y utilizar un color
diferente aquí hablamos de un grupo de
h2 y no teníamos ningún centro quiral
como estos dos protones de aquí no
teníamos ningún centro quiral en esta
molécula estos dos protones son
generalmente equivalentes pero si pienso
en eso por aquí tengo un centro que irá
en este carbono y eso afectará a estos
dos protones estos dos protones ya no
son químicamente equivalentes porque hay
un centro que irá al presente en general
si un centro que ir al está presente los
dos protones en el grupo metilo en un
grupo ch2 son generalmente no
equivalentes
así que esperaríamos dos señales
diferentes
podría darnos una
genial
escribiré eso en magenta una señal aquí
y con este esperaríamos una
lineal distinta son ambientes
ligeramente diferentes
debido a este centro que irá al presente
continuamos y descubramos cuántas
señales más deberíamos esperar por aquí
tenemos a estos tres protones que son
químicamente equivalentes y están en su
propio ambiente
esperamos una
genial
para esos tres protones y esos están en
un ambiente diferente
estos de aquí esperaríamos una
señal
para el grupo metilo los protones del
metilo siempre están en el mismo
ambiente por lo que son equivalentes
químicamente no tienes que preocuparte
por ellos y ahora veamos qué más tenemos
aquí tenemos el protón en el oxígeno así
que esperaríamos una
real
a eso y luego finalmente finalmente
tendremos veamos qué color debería
escoger aquí usemos el naranja tenemos
un protón aquí en su propio ambiente
esperaríamos
real para ese protón cuántas señales
esperamos en total contemos las 12
5 y 6 un total de seis señales esperadas
para este alcohol continuemos con un
anillo de benceno por aquí
y sabemos que el benceno tiene 6
protones puedo incluir los 6 protones
y todos esos seis protones están
exactamente en el mismo ambiente todos
son químicamente equivalentes y algunas
veces es más sencillo solo dibujar un
círculo aquí
y eso te ayudará a ver que estos
protones son equivalentes ayuda a ver la
simetría un poco mejor
nuevamente pensando en la simetría todos
los 6 protones están en el mismo
ambiente debido a eso esperamos solo una
señal para el benceno en un espectro de
rm n déjame continuar dibujando esto
aquí una sólo una
señal para el benceno porque todos los 6
protones son químicamente equivalentes
continuaré con estas moléculas de abajo
pensemos en lo que tenemos tenemos un
grupo de tilo aquí y un grupo metilo
aquí esos son 3 protones 3 protones para
cada grupo metilo y esos protones están
en el mismo ambiente estos 3 protones en
este grupo metilo están en el mismo
ambiente que estos 3 protones están
junto a un oxígeno que está junto a este
anillo de benceno
justo a un oxígeno junto a un anillo de
benceno y entonces esperaríamos sólo una
señal sólo una
y al para estos seis protones de aquí si
vemos nuestro anillo si vemos nuestro
anillo sabemos que hay un protón aquí
sabemos que hay un protón aquí un protón
aquí y un protón aquí y si pensamos en
estos protones todos están exactamente
en el mismo ambiente si pienso en este
protón este protón está al lado de un c
h con un doble enlace está junto a un
carbono justo aquí con el oxígeno este
está en el mismo ambiente que éste éste
está exactamente en el mismo ambiente
este también y este también así que
nuevamente la simetría ayuda a darnos
cuenta que todos los cuatro protones
están en el mismo ambiente son
químicamente equivalentes por lo que
esperamos
miel
esperaríamos ver dos señales
esperaríamos ver dos señales para esta
molécula en el espectro de rm n
finalmente sólo por diversión veamos
este cubano de aquí una de las moléculas
más interesantes en mi opinión hay 8
protones en el cubano el cubano es solo
este cubo de aquí y sus 8 protones son
todos equivalentes pensamos que si solo
rotamos este cubo no habría una
diferencia aquí así que tenemos 8
protones todos equivalentes y por lo
tanto sólo una señal el espectro de rm
del cubano deberá solo tener una
real en él
bien espero eso sea una introducción de
cómo viendo un diagrama de puntos
podemos descubrir cuántas señales
esperar en tu espectro de rm n